- "Stand by" sur les côtés!
- Des élèves de quatrième
secondaire en répétition.
- La premiere fois, je dois
avouer que j'ai trouvé
le bâtiment assez beau.
- Le spectacle collectif
qui réunit des artistes
du théâtre, des enseignants
et une centaine d'élèves
de l'École Sophie-Barat
s'intitule "Habiter les ruines".
- Moi, j'ai peur qu'on laisse
l'école se dégrader, qu'on
rajoute encore plus de grillage,
plus de clôtures.
- Une chance qu'il y a
le terrain, qu'il y a
la rivière puis les arbres,
puis nos casiers etaient
rouillés puis quand ils les ont
changés, ils les ont remplacés
par des casiers trop petits.
- La moitié de l'école a été
condamnée, il y a un peu plus
d'un an.
MICHEL STRINGER, enseignant
de français, école Sophie-Barat
- Quand on a appris,
dans le fond, que le toit était
sur le point de s'effondrer,
donc ça a été un drame carrément
pour l'école parce qu'il y a
une partie des élèves
qui ont dû être délocalisés.
- Ceux qui restent, les grands
de 4e et 5e secondaire, n'ont
plus accès à la cafétéria,
ni à la bibliothèque,
qui venait d'être rénovée.
Dans la classe de francais
de Michel Stringer, le thème
du patrimoine s'est donc imposé.
- C'est sûr, refaire les murs,
mais aussi refaire
les planchers en bois franc
qu'on avait dans le passé,
ça serait cool.
- Qu'on règle la situation peut-
être un peu avant que
le probleme nous éclate
à la face.
- Je réalise, cette école,
elle a quand même beaucoup
d'histoire et il faut préserver
ce patrimoine, se souvenir
que c'est grâce aux gens
qui se sont investis qu'on a
une école comme ça.
FRÉDÉRIQUE GAGNÉ-THIBAULT,
chargée de projet en patrimoine
- Donc, ça témoigne aussi
de l'évolution de l'éducation
au Québec parce qu'on avait
au départ un pensionnat privé
pour jeunes filles puis dans
les années 70, ça devient
un secondaire public, ouvert
aux garcons aussi.
- L'école Sophie-Barat est
la plus vielle école du CSSDM,
un site rempli d'histoire situé
au bord de la Rivière
des Prairies.
- C'est un bâtiment qui est
complexe parce que c'est
une addition finalement d'ailes
qui se sont ajoutées au fil
du temps. Donc, le pavillon
principal datait de 1855,
auquel on a ajouté une aile
ouest, une aile est, une aile
nord, un externat, puis enfin
une aile en 1912. Tout ça a
passé au feu malheureusement
en 1929.
- Ce sera aussi le plus
important projet de rénovation
et d'agrandissement du CSSDM.
Québec y a consenti
164 millions $.
- Moi, ça fait 25 ans que
j'enseigne ici et j'ai vu
le bâtiment dépérir au fil
des années.
- Mon rôle comme enseignant
de français, c'est de faire
lire, de faire écrire,
c'est de les placer dans
des situations où ils peuvent
prendre la parole.
- Moi, j'ai peur que l'école
s'écroule puis qu'on soit
obligés de finir nos cours
dans les ruines.
- Mais c'est une école publique,
donc c'est normal.
- (ensemble): Mais c'est une
école publique, donc c'est
normal.
- Des élèves nous ont dit
souhaiter que parmi
les 400 spectateurs, se
trouveront ceux qui décideront
comment sera rénovée et agrandie
l'École Sophie Barat.
Ici ALD,
Radio-Canada, M